okay hi if you're on let's get started
again okay so first of all let me just
say a bit about
assignment 5 so assignment 5 is coming
out today
it's a brand new assignment so you guys
are the guinea pigs for that and so what
it's going to be it essentially builds
on assignment 4 so it's okay if you
didn't do perfectly an assignment 4
though I think actually most people did
and what we're going to be doing is
adding convolutional neural networks and
sub word modeling to the neuro machine
translation system seeking it to make it
better so this assignment is coding
heavy written questions light so I mean
the coding that you have to do sort of
isn't actually really more difficult
than assignment 4 it's kind of like
assignment 4 but what we're hoping is
that this time you will be able to do it
on your own like what I mean by that is
for assignment 4 well there was tons of
scaffolding telling you what everything
should be and there were all of these
autograder checks and you could keep on
working on your code until they passed
all the auto grader checks and everybody
did and so it was very kind of cuddled
shall we say but I mean I guess what
we're really wanting to achieve is they
have a monocyte question yes so what
we're hoping is that this can be useful
it'll be short term pain but useful as
being a more effective ramp to doing the
final project and indeed for the rest of
your life right I didn't love the
reality is than the rest of your life
you sort of if you're going to be doing
things with deep learning you kind of
have to work out what kind of model to
build and which pieces to stitch
together and how to write some tests to
see if it's doing something sensible and
if it's not doing something sensible to
figure out how you could change things
and try different things and get it to
work sensibly and so that's what we're
hoping that people can do in assignment
5 so if you've got of figure things out
should write your own testing code we
don't have a public autograder so you
should that's part of working out your
own sanity checks trying to do things
like what I talked about last week of
sort of getting simple bits working
confirming that they work on minut
amounts of test data and so on and doing
things more sensibly I mean in
particular the one particular part of
that that we were planning to do for
this assignment I was looking for it but
it's on the next slide so for this
assignment and beyond we're going to
enforce rules like more like they are
and CS 107 for those of you who are
undergrads meaning that the TAS don't
look at and debug your code for you and
so you know of course we still want ta
used to be helpful come to them with
your problems talk about how you're
meant to use different things in the
Python library but you shouldn't be
regarding it as the TAS job of here's a
big Python file can you tell me what's
wrong with it
and fix it up for you okay
the precise policy for that written up
on Piazza okay so up to any questions
about that or do I go straight on in
okay yes so today's lecture in some
sense today's lecture is an easy lecture
so last times lecture there was really
sort of a ton of new stuff of other
stuff and your networks that you haven't
seen before
and we did Khan finet and we did pooling
layers and we did highway and residual
connections and batch norms and I know
whatever else you did size one
convolutions I guess so there are tons
of new stuff really in this lecture in
terms of sort of neural network
machinery there isn't any new stuff at
all so this is really
and this is also really a new lecture
but it was sort of put in for a reason
and the reason for this relates to a
kind of remark I made last time about
how lots of stuff keeps changing in
neural network land so at the time we
first designed this class and the way
that a lot of the structure of it still
is that sort of around in 2014/15 when
we designed this class it was basically
axiomatic that all deep learning models
for natural language processing worked
off words and therefore it completely
made sense that we start with word
vectors and then we start looking at
things like recurrent models over words
whereas the fact of the matter is in the
last approximately three years there's
been a ton of new work including some of
the most influential new work
there's building language models that
isn't isn't art being built over words
that they're building built over pieces
of words or characters and so this
lecturers sort of meant to give you some
sense of these other ways of doing
things and some orientation to some of
the things that's going on but the
actual kind of models that we're looking
at are sort of using all of the building
blocks that we've already looked at
things like RN ins and commnets
and things like that so let's get into
this so I'm gonna start off with a teeny
bit of linguistics of learning about the
structure of language and for sort of
lower-level units of language and then
we'll see how that pans out for things
like character level models so in
linguistics if you start at the bottom
of the totem pole the first level of
linguistics is phonetics which is sort
of understanding the sounds and the
physiology of human speech so that's
sort of like physics or physiology or
something right there our mouth parts
that move there our ear parts that act
as filters and there's audio waves in
between the two of them so that's kind
of uncontroversial in some sense but
above that level the
standard thing that people do for the
analysis of human languages is to say
well human languages may seem to make
use of a relatively small set of
distinctive units which then commonly
called phonemes which are actually
categorical and the idea here is that
well now now mouths are continuous
spaces right that they've got these
various bits of their mouths like you
know tongues and pharynx is and so on
but it's a continuous space so actually
we can make an infinite variety of
sounds right so if I open my mouth and
apply boy sing and just wiggle my tongue
around I can go and I can make a in the
infinite variety of different sounds but
the reality is that human languages
aren't like that that out of that
infinite variety of sounds we
distinguish a small space of sounds and
something that happens when languages
change is that the space of sounds that
are seen as important and distinguished
in a language change and that happens
even within side one language as is
English and I'm about to give an example
of that so people in COG psyche talk
about the phenomenon of categorical
perception and what that means is that
really there's something continuous but
that humans perceive it as belonging to
fairly sharp categories and you know you
can use that for sort of you know styles
of clothing or whether someone counts as
fat or not but the most famous examples
of categorical perception are in
language where we can make an infinite
variety of sounds but people perceive
them as categories and so effectively
what that means is when you have
categorical perception that differences
within a category sort of perceived to
have shrunk you barely notice them at
all where differences across categories
are expanded and very clear and so one
of the cases
that sort of studied a lot is what's
called referred to as sort of voice
onset time so lots of languages
including English have pairs of sounds
like P and B apart and a bar and they
differ based on when voicing starts at
birth is has a voice sound like a vowel
with an R in it and well that's a
continuous parameter you can sort of
make any point along a spectrum between
a P and a B but human beings who speak
English perceive just two points on that
spectrum and you don't sort of really
notice the fine differences between them
some languages to distinguish more
points on the spectrum so Thai
distinguishes three different consonant
sounds in depending on the voice onset
time something that might be more
accessible to you is this is an example
of language change so for speaker like
me
there is caught and caught and those are
different vowels and I hear them as
different vowels but if you are someone
who grew up in the southwest of the
United States then these are exactly the
same value and you don't distinguish
them that you thought I said the same
thing twice even though I was saying two
different vowels and so that's where in
even at a dialectal ish level that
people develop categorical perception as
to which which distinctions and sounds
they're sensitive to or not sensitive to
okay and stomach and I mean why I'm
mentioning this is in some senses these
sound distinctions of categorical sound
distinctions that are what a lot of our
language writing systems that we'll come
to in a minute record okay
so in traditional linguistics you have
sounds but sounds don't have any
meanings and language Soperton ber
don't have meanings and art and II don't
have meanings and so people then
normally distinguish as the next level
up morphology is parts of words and this
is seen as the minimal level that has
mean
and so the idea is lots of words are
complex and can be made made up of
pieces but these pieces do have meaning
so fortune has a meaning fortunate you
end in this 8 ending which sort of gives
it gives fortune to somebody so that
means you're having fortune that has a
meaning
unhhhh has a meaning which means to
reverse that so unfortunate means that
you don't have fortune and Lee then has
a meaning of turning this all into an
adverb and you can say unfortunately not
having gotten fortune something happened
and so these sort of pieces of words are
then the minimal things that have
meanings
I'm almost no work in deep learning has
tried to make use of this sort of
morpheme level of structure actually me
and a couple of students six years ago
did actually try and build a system
where it built these tree structured
neural networks that put together
meanings of words out of their pieces
but that really isn't an idea that's
taken on widely there's sort of a reason
why it hasn't taken on widely which is
doing this and working out there
semantically meaningful pieces of words
is kind of hard and a lot of the time in
NLP what people have found is you can
just about get the same kind of results
if you just work with character engrams
the kind of units that you put into the
convolutional neural nets because if you
just have a model that uses character
trigrams and you have sort of started
word on and nfo and so on for going
through the ly end of word that those
different units there's different
character trigrams in a distributed way
will pick up all the important meaning
components of the word pretty well and
that that's just good enough and that's
actually a very classic idea that sort
of been revived so back in the second
coming of neural networks in the mid 80s
into the early 90s there was
have that was quite a bit of sort of
controversial work on the structure of
language and in particular Dave
rumelhart and Jay McClelland so Jamie :
still in the psych department here if
you want to look him up in your spare
time they proposed a model of how to
model generating past tense forms in
English so this was sort of a cog Tsai
experiment of can we build a system that
can learn past tenses of English verbs
and the difficult part there is some
many verbs and regular you add the kind
of edy ending but some words are
irregular and you had to sort of learn
about the irregular patterning but the
way they did that I mean partly because
this was sort of early days with respect
to sequence models is that they used a
representation where they represented
words precisely with these sort of
character trigrams and that was the
representation of words they used and
fed forward in their model and that idea
was met with a lot of controversy by
linguists philosophers and other people
with their ideas of language and so
there's a lot of debate in those days
about that but from as a purely
engineering solution that sort of proved
to be a pretty good way to do things and
so this decade there's been other work
which includes the model developed a
Microsoft Office over deeps semantics
model where what they're using is these
kind of character engrams to put meaning
over words okay so so now we might be
interested in building models that
aren't over words so we're going to have
a word written as characters and we're
going to do something with it such as
build character engrams and so something
that is just useful to know is you know
there's actually a fair amount of
variation between languages when you do
this so it's not all the same stuff
right so the first problem is there are
some languages that don't put spaces
between words the most famous example is
Chinese but an interesting fact for
those people of European
ancestry is that you know if for when
the ancient Greeks wrote ancient Greek
they didn't put spaces between words
either it was actually a later invention
of medieval scholars who are recopying
their manuscripts who they decided well
maybe they'd be easier to read if we put
spaces in and that they started doing it
most languages these days do put spaces
in between words but even then there are
sort of a lot of fine cases so in
particular a lot of languages have some
sort of little bits of stuff which might
be pronouns or prepositions or various
kind of joining words like and and so
and which sometimes they write together
and sometimes separately so in French
you get these kind of prepositional I'm
sorry pronominal markers for you I you
have brought and you know these kind of
little words and pronunciation just sort
of run together as you lose a and
arguably it's almost one word that it's
written as separate words where there
are other languages which sort of stick
things together where arguably they're
separate words so in Arabic you get
pronominal clinics and some of these
sort of joining words like so an end and
that they're sort of written together as
one word where arguably that they should
really be four words another famous case
of that is with compound nouns so in
English we write compound nouns with
spaces between them so you can see each
noun even though in many respects
compound nouns something like white
board behaves like it's one word or high
school whereas other languages German is
the most famous case but also other
Germanic languages just write them
always one word and you get very long
words like that so we're going to get
different words if we just knew spaces
and don't do much else
I'm good okay yeah so for dealing with
words there are these practical problems
and we sort of already started to touch
on them that if you try and build word
based models there's this huge space of
words and while strictly there's an
infinite space of words because once you
allow and things like numbers let alone
FedEx routing numbers or or if you allow
and just morphology when you can make
those ones like unfortunately you're
sort of you can just expand the space of
words so you get this large open
vocabulary English you know a bit
problematic it gets way more problematic
in a lot of other languages so here's a
lovely Czech word to the worst farmable
one where you can make sort of much more
complex words and lots of other
languages many Native American languages
are the European languages like Finnish
have these sort of very complex words
Turkish has very complex words so that's
bad news there are other reasons we'd
like to be able to look at words below
the word level to know things about them
so when you're translating there's a
wide space of things especially names
where translation is essentially
transliteration that you're going to
rewrite the sound of somebody's name as
roughly you know and perhaps not
perfectly correctly but roughly
correctly according to the sound systems
of the different language and well if we
want to do that we essentially want to
work operate at the letter level not the
word level but another huge modern
reason why we'd like to start modeling
below the word level is we live in this
age of social media and if you're in the
social media land there's a lot of stuff
that's written not using the canonical
words that you find in the dictionary
and somehow we'd want to start to model
that so in some sense this is the easy
case goodbye
but nevertheless this is spelt with one
two three four five six seven zeroes and
one two three four oh and also seven SS
they match I don't know that's delivery
odd okay so this style of writing is
very common and well you know we kind of
sunk if we're treating things that the
word level and we're trying to model
this right that's clearly not what human
beings are doing with sort of looking at
the characters and recognizing what goes
on in some sense that's kind of the easy
case that you could imagine
pre-processing out there's a lot of
harder stuff that then turns up I guess
they're sort of the abbreviation speak
if I don't care but then you sort of get
a lot of creative Spelling's that come
off of kind of reduced pronunciations
like imma go summon and it seems like
somehow we need something other than
canonical words if we're going to start
to deal better with a lot of this text
okay so that suggests we sort of want to
start doing that with our models and so
that's led to a lot of interest in using
character level models and I mean there
are sort of to extent of which you can
do this and we'll look at them both a
bit one level is to say look we're still
going to have words and our system
basically we're going to build a system
that works over words but we want to be
able to create word representations for
any character sequence and we'd like to
do it in a way that takes advantage of
being able to recognize parts of the
character sequence that look familiar so
that we can probably guess what Vybz
means and so that sort of then solves
the problems with unknown words and we
get similar words similar embeddings for
words with similar
Spelling's etc but the
the alternative is to say ha no just
forget about these words all together
who needs them why don't we just do all
of our language processing on sequence
of characters it'll work out fine both
of these methods have been proven to
work very successfully and I just wanted
to dwell on that for one moment and that
sort of goes back to my morphology slide
here when people first started proposing
that they are going to build deep
learning models over characters I mean
my first feeling was how that is never
gonna work because it sort of seemed
like okay words have a meaning it makes
sense that you can do something like
build a word to Veck model and that's
gonna really be able to sort of see
words in their distribution and learn
the meanings of the words because words
have a meaning the idea that you're
going to be able to say well I'm going
to come up with a vector representation
of H and a different vector
representation of a and a different
vector representation of T and somehow
that will be useful for representing
what a hat means once I put it through
enough neural network layers frankly
sounded pretty unconvincing to me but I
guess you know but it totally works so
I'm convinced now pinnacle proof and I
think what we sort of essentially need
to realize is that with going that yes
it's some level we just have these
characters that don't mean much but we
then have these very powerful
combinatory models with a lot of
parameters in them things like recurrent
neural networks and convolutional neural
networks and that they're effectively
able to sort of built store and build
representations of meaning from multi
letter groups in such a way that they
can model the meanings and morphemes and
larger units and therefore put together
word meanings yeah so on one more detail
on using characters from writing systems
so if you're a linguist you tend to
think of
sounds as primary those were the
phonemes that we I mentioned beforehand
you know essentially deep learning
hasn't tried to use phonemes at all
traditional speech recognizers often did
use phonemes but in the deep learning
land you want to have a lot of data and
the way you get a lot of data is you
just use written stuff because you know
it's the easily found data where you can
get millions and billions of words of
stuff so that sort of makes sense from a
data point of view but the thing that
ends up is a little weird about that is
that when you're then building a
character level model what your
character level model is actually varies
depending on the writing system of the
language and so you kind of have these
quite different writing systems so you
have some writing systems which are just
completely phonemic that there are
letters that have a particular sound and
you say that sound something like
Spanish is pretty much phonemic
sometimes it's a teeny bit complicated
so you might have a digraph so this
digraph
now bulu is kind of like the ng of
English that is used for in sound like
at the end of sing but you know
basically this is just G whoo each
letters a sound you can read it and it's
just phonemic that then contrasts from
something like English where all the
non-native speakers know the spelling is
terrible it's got this sort of highly
fossilized once-upon-a-time phonemic
system in the 10th century or something
but now we have this system that words
have fairly arbitrary spelling that
doesn't actually represent the sounds
very clearly but it's sort of a phonemic
system but then there are languages that
use larger units this is Canadian and
neuter toot which I just put in there
because it's such a pretty writing
system but there are a lot of languages
that represent syllables by their
characters so you have something like
this in Korean for example with Korean
Hangul that each letter is then being a
syllable of this sort of consonant vowel
combination like
you can then go up a level from that and
if we get back to Chinese again well
this is sort of also a syllabic system
you could say but really the Chinese
characters are much more than just the
sound they also have a meaning that this
is really then an idea graphic system
where there are characters with
particular meanings attached to them so
they're sort of whole morphemes in
written as one letter and you know
another example of such language was
Egyptian hieroglyphs if you've seen
those that they're sort of a geographic
systems where you have letters with
meanings and then you have language
systems that sort of mix several of
those so Japanese is sort of a mixture
of partly Marea partly idea graphics
system mixed together so if you just
sort of start off and say okay I'm gonna
build a character based system that's
fine but effectively your character
units like letter trigrams are just very
different in a language like Chinese
we're commonly a letter trigram will be
sort of a word and a half three
morphemes with meaning whereas if you're
in something like English your character
trigram will be something like th au
which is still sort of much too small at
unit to have any meaning so moving right
ahead so these two kind of approaches
one was just do a completely character
level model and then the other one was
sort of make use of characters to build
bigger things that you're then going to
put something like into a more word
level model so I'll do this one first
and the other one so for a purely
character level models I actually showed
an example of that last time do you
remember so there was that very deep
convolutional network from the Kanoa Tao
work for text classification at the end
and that just started with a big line of
characters and built these convolutional
layers on top of that in the vision like
network and classified the documents so
that was sort of a completely character
level model but here's a bit more work
on this so people for machine
translation have built machine
translation
systems that just read characters and
write characters and when people first
tried to do that it sort of didn't work
right the people thought it might help
to build character level models
especially for languages like Chinese
but people just weren't able to build
models that worked as well as word based
models in need of a pre neural manam
neural or the neural world and but
gradually that started to change so
people start to have successful
character level decoders and then sort
of around 2015 16 people started to show
look you could can actually do machine
translation very well at just a
character level with a few asterisks and
so here's a bit of work that we did and
the long many one from 2015 on the last
slide so this is looking at English to
check translation and checks a good
language to use if you want to motivate
doing things at the character level
because it has those big horrible words
with lots of morphology like the example
I showed you before and I'll show you
some more later so people had built word
level models for check and you know they
didn't work great partly because of some
of these vocab problems so the sort of
word level state of the art was at this
time was fifteen point seven blue which
as you know is much less than we will
accept for full grades and your homework
but you know what counts as a good blue
score depends on how difficult the
language pair is and so you're not doing
check but so this was sort of the kind
of new LMT model that we've talked about
so as a seek to seek model with
attention and then it had extra stuff
for substituting chunks with either
single word translation or by copying
stuff from the source so as sort of
basically state-of-the-art neural Mt of
2015 got 15.7 blue
and the difference isn't big but we were
able to show look we could build this
completely character level model
actually better so this sort of showed
that in terms of translation quality
character purely character based models
were completely viable at capturing the
meaning of text as well as word based
with models was this a great result in
maybe in some ways yes and in another
way no I mean this model was control eat
arable to Train right so it took about
three weeks for us to train this model
and at runtime it also worked very
slowly and so the problem with character
level models if you're putting them into
something like an LS TM is your
sequences get way longer right so you've
got about seven times as long sequences
as you used to have and since there's
not much information the characters you
have to do back propagation through time
much further back and so we were running
back propagation through time for 600
steps before your trend truncating it
and so this sort of made maybe that was
excessive but it made the models very
slow but we were able to show that was
able to get some of these good effects
right so here's a check I'm translating
to check her 11 year old daughter
Shawnee Bart said it felt a little bit
weird and I don't know probably does
anyone speak Czech any Czech speakers no
Czech speakers okay
I don't speak Czech either but we can
see we can see that this does
interesting things that so the second
line is the human translation into Czech
which we can use for some guidance and
so in particular in Czech there's a word
for eleven years old which you can see
is that blue word on the second line and
you can see that despite eleven-year-old
was that for eleven-year-old it's just
able to perfectly produce letter by
letter the Czech word for eleven years
old and that works beautifully in
contrast for the word level model
eleven-year-old was an unknown word
because that wasn't in the vocabulary
and so then it had two mechanisms to try
and deal with unknown words could either
do a unigram translation of them or it
could just copy them and for whatever
reason it sided here the best strategy
was to copy and so that was a complete
fail and if we go along for the
character level model another thing that
gets right that's really cool is the
name shiny Bart it's able to do this
transliteration tasks that I mentioned
just perfectly and it turns them into
shiny Bart over which is exactly what
the human translator did as well and so
you know it's actually doing some really
kind of nice human translator like
things I mean in in fact as best I can
tell from spending a bit of time on
Google Translate it actually does a
pretty good job in the sentence period
right this part here starts to be
different from the human translator but
it's not actually bad it's sort of a
more literal translation so this Chiti
actually translates feel like in the
english text whereas the human sort of
didn't actually use the word feel and
the czech version that they just went
was a little bit weird or strange so
that's cool okay so here are a couple
more results from this so here's another
system that was built the next year by
these people Jason Lee Kyung Hyun Cho
and Thomas Hoffman so they wanted to do
something that was I don't know much
more complex and neural and
understanding the meaning of the text on
the source side and so they were more
using the kind of technologies we saw
last time so on the encoder side you
started off with a letter sequence of
character embeddings
and then you're sort of using
convolutions of four three and five
characters to get representations up
here
you're then doing a max pulling with the
stride of five so you're getting a max
pulled representation of pieces of the
text for each of the three four and five
convolutions you know then feeding that
through multiple layers of highway
network and feeding that through a
bi-directional gated recurrent unit and
that's given you your source
representation on the decoder side it
was sort of the same as our decoder was
just running a character level sequence
model so overall so they were doing this
um or they were doing the opposite task
this is checked to English but so
they're staying to get better scores but
I mean actually if you're sort of
looking at these different numbers where
I'll explain this system more in a
minute I mean it sort of seems like the
place where they get a lot of value is
that using the character level decoder
gives them a lot of value but this very
complex model on the source side is
giving them almost no value at all one
more even more recent paper so this has
: cherry and fellow researchers at
Google so they last year did one more
exploration of doing lsdm sequence the
sequence style models of comparing word
and character based models and this is
English to French and this is Czech to
English with just what we were doing and
so in both cases when you have a big
model the character model wins for them
the blue model comes out on top
but the sort of interesting thing is you
sort of see these different effects
depending on the morphological
complexity of the language so for a
language like Czech it's a really good
idea if you want to build a good model
to use character level that they're
getting about a blue point of difference
there whereas for a
model without putting French or English
that's actually a tiny but very little
gain from using a character level model
okay so let me just explain these models
so these models and models of different
sizes so these models are using
bi-directional LS TM encoders and one
directional lsdm decoders so the
simplest model just has a shallow
bi-directional lsdm encoder and a 2
layer l STM decoder the middle model has
a three deep stack of bi-directional
lsdm encoders and a four deep stack of
LS TM decoders and the most complex
model has a six deep stack of
bi-directional STM encoders and an eight
deep stack of LS TM decoders this is
where it helps to work at Google
probably for your projects you don't
want to go beyond three or four stay
over here okay yeah so so these are the
results so basically what you're finding
is if you're making sort of smaller
models you're better off with words but
as you go to big models especially if
you're in a morphologically rich
language you clearly start to win from
the characters but there is still a loss
which is essentially exactly the same
loss that we were suffering from the
from 2015 right this is the the time
graph and so these are the same three
models as over here it's just the axis
has changed a sort of sum the total
number of lsdm layers and so that you
know essentially if you're at the word
level you can run any of these three
models and they are fast that you can be
translating in sort of not much time but
for the character level models your
slope is much higher so it starts to get
quite expensive to run the deep
character level models
okay so that's that section so then
chugging along I then wanted to look at
other ways of doing things and so these
are models that in some sense still do
have words but we're we're going to want
to sort of build word representations
out of pieces and they're essentially
two families of ways that people have
explored doing this one way of doing it
is to say look we just want to use
exactly the same architecture as we use
for a word model except when our words
aren't really going to be words at least
sometimes they're going to be pieces of
words and so those are often called word
piece models and in particular there's
one communist way of doing it was called
bpe
which I'll go through in some detail the
other alternative is to say well we're
going to kind of make a mixture or a
hybrid so our main model is going to
work in terms of words but we're going
to have some kind of facility where we
can construct a representation for
otherwise unknown words by doing things
that a character or a lower-level
and I'll show you a bit of that as well
okay so this is BP BP is actually a
pretty simple idea which has nothing to
do with deep learning but the use of BP
is sort of become pretty standard and
successful for representing pieces of
words to allow you to have an infinite
vocabulary well at an infinite effective
vocabulary while actually working with a
finite vocabulary so the origins of bite
pair and coding and the name bite pair
is nothing to do with natural language
processing on your nets we're just
writing a compression algorithm so this
is something like you know compressing
your documents with gzip so what basic
white pair encoding is that you've got
collection of stuff with bytes and
you're looking for the most frequent
sequence of two bytes and you say okay
I'm going to add that sequence of two
bytes as a new element to my dictionary
of possible values and that means I can
have two hundred and fifty seven
different values for a byte so to speak
that I can shrink the length of my
sequence and I can repeat over and do
that again and so essentially this work
suggested well we could apply this kind
of compression algorithm and use it as a
way of coming up with pieces of words
that we useful doing it not strictly
with bytes despite the name but instead
with characters and character engrams
and so the most common way to do this is
with characters and character m grams
and if you're up with modern times you
know that means there's unicode and you
can represent all of these lovely
letters like Canadian and neuter tooths
syllabics and stuff like that but you
know there's actually a problem with
Unicode which is you know there are
actually a lot of Unicode characters I
forget the number theoretically I think
this for two hundred thousand possible
Unicode characters but anyway if you
want to handle a bunch of languages
which include East Asian languages maybe
you need something like 20,000
characters and that's sort of a lot so
there are actually some people who've
literally gone back to bytes and said
you know 200,000 that's a really big
vocabulary I don't want to deal with
anything sorry 20,000 is a really big
vocabulary I don't even want to deal
with anything that large so why don't I
actually just do these kind of
algorithms over bytes and so that means
that in utf-8 encoding Chinese
characters take three bytes each and so
you actually have two and you only get
whole characters if you've actually
merged together several bytes that are
common sequences okay so more concretely
how does this work so we sort of doing
this bottom-up clustering of short
sequences so we start with a unigram
vocabulary which is all of the Unicode
characters in some data we then sort of
ask what's the most frequent in Graham
here initially you'll be a bigram pair
and we add that to our vocabulary so if
we start off you know we can take our
text that's I'll come back to this in a
minute let's assume we have a text that
has been divided into words so we do
have word tokens and so we can represent
it as a dictionary and say here are some
words with their frequency and so now we
look for a common letter sequence and we
say oh yes that occurs nine times in
this data because we have the counts for
the words on the left side so we start
with our vocabulary being all the
individual letters we find a communist
letter sequence like es and so we say
let's clump that together and make that
a new thing in our vocabulary so now
we've got an extra thing in our
vocabulary and now what's the Communist
Ingram's sequence a clump something well
actually all of these es s are followed
by T so we also have est with frequency
9 and so we can add that to our
vocabulary and then we ask again well
what's another common letter sequence
let's see there are seven cases of O
double fault I guess there are seven
cases of either L o or o W so we can
lump those and then we can lump again
and make an L o W so if we sort of run
this we start to build these clumps of
common letter sequences and so common
bits like est but also just common words
something like that in English will very
quickly become together and be a unit
about vocabulary and so we do that for a
while so normally what we do is we
decide a vocabulary size that we want to
work with we say okay I want to work
with the vocabulary size of a thing
and words that'll mean my model will be
fast and we just sort of keep doing this
until we have 8,000 things in our
vocabulary and that means our vocabulary
will have in it all single letters
because we started with them and it'll
have common subsequences of words like
the es and est there now no vocabulary
but also have whole words whenever their
comments and words like you know that
and - and with and so on will become
parts of our vocabulary and so then when
we have a piece of text we can do a
deterministic longest piece segmentation
of words and we will say that is now set
of word pieces and so for an input piece
of text we turn into word pieces and
then we just run it through our MT
system as if we were using words but
really it's pieces of words and then on
the output side we just concatenate them
back together as needed okay so we get
this automatic word based system and
that's proved to be a very successful
system so this idea of using bite pair
encoding sort of really emerged in 2015
and in the 2016 workshop on machine
translation which has been the main sort
of annual competition for MT systems
that the several top systems were built
using bite pair and coding if you look
at last year's competition there's a bit
more variety but really a number of the
top systems are still using bite pair
and coding that's just been a good way
to do things
so for Google's Newell machine
translation they effectively use them a
variant of bite Peron coding so they
don't use exactly the same algorithm
they use a slightly different algorithm
where they're using a language model and
they're saying what what rather than
just using pure counts they're saying
what clumping together would maximally
reduce the perplexity of my language
model and clump those things and repeat
over and so they did they've done too
versions of this model so the first
version the word piece model kind of
like bite parent coding assume that you
have an initial tokenization two words
and then you just sort of having pieces
of words using this algorithm and then
they did a second version the sentence
piece model which you can find at this
github side which said well it's
problematic if we need to tokenize in
two words first because then we need to
have a tokenizer for every language and
that's a lot of work so maybe instead of
that we could just sort of treat go from
a character sequence retain white spaces
and regard that as something that's part
of the clumping process and so that you
just build your word pieces which
commonly will have spaces on one side or
the other of them because often things
inside a word are the common or more
common clumps and you build those up and
that's proven to be quite successful in
particular one place where some of you
might see this is we've yet to get to
describing it in the class really but
there's been this recent work which we
actually talk about next week in class
on building these transformer models in
particular google has released this bert
model which gives you very good word
representations and if you download bert
and try and use it what you will find
out is it doesn't operate over words it
operates over word pieces and so it has
a large vocabulary it's not a vocabulary
of like 8,000 words I forget the number
but the models have a large vocabulary
but they're still not a huge vocabulary
and it's using word P so so lots of
words are in the vocabulary so if you
look at the English model it not only
has word like F in it but it even has
worse like Fairfax and 19-teens which
aren't that common but it's nevertheless
to cover all words it's again using this
word piece idea so if I want to
representation
for word Hypatia that's not in the
vocabulary and so I'm making it up of
pieces there's an H representation and
then in the Bert version which is
different to the Google nmt version the
non the non initial word pieces are
represented with two hashes at the start
so I can put that together with H at YP
etc and this would be my representation
of Hypatia
so effectively I have word vectors for
for word pieces and then I have to work
out what to do with them the simplest
and quite common way as I just average
the four of them and they're obviously
other things you could do you could
confident a next poll or you could run a
little LS TM or something to put
together representation okay yeah so so
those were the models that sort of
worked with pieces of words to give you
infinite vocabulary and ran them through
a normal system the other possibility is
to say well we want to work with
characters so we can deal with an
infinite vocabulary but we're going to
sort of incorporate those into a bigger
system and a whole bunch of work has
done this and in some sense it's a
fairly obvious thing to do so this work
in 2014 was one of the early ones so
they said well we could start with
characters we can do a convolution over
the characters to generate word
embeddings and then we can use those
word embeddings for something in a
higher level model this was actually
sort of a fixed window model for doing
part of speech tagging that makes sense
instead of a convolution you could use
LS TM so this was worked for me here
later and they said well we're also
going to build up word representations
from characters and the way we're going
to do it is we're going to run character
level bio STM's concatenate the two
final states and we're going to call
that our word representation and then
we're going to put that
word representation into language model
which is then a higher-level LS TM that
works along sequence of words and I
thought I just oh yeah so yeah so if
you're learning you look I mean this is
the hidden layer I guess I'm not
actually showing the input layer but the
input layer your learning vector for
each character so effectively you're
doing the same kind of thing we saw
before that you're starting with random
representations for each character
you've got this embedded inside a word
sequence LS TM your goal is to minimize
the perplexity of the higher level LS TM
as as a language model and so it's
filters back its gradient so it's
wanting to come up with character
vectors such that if it produces good
word vectors which produces low
perplexities good question so here's a
slightly more complex version of trying
to do this that's a bit more recent
where again the idea is can we build a
good language model by starting out from
characters and wanting to exploit sort
of related some words and rare words and
so they built sort of this kind of more
stacked complex model that will go
through the stages of where for we start
with a word representatives characters
we have character embeddings
which we build into a convolutional
network and then we head upwards so if
you take that one piece at a time
so you have a character embedding for
each character
you're then have a convolutional layer
which then sort of rep has various
filters that work over those character
sequence of two three and four grams of
characters so getting
representations of parts of words then
from those convolutional networks you're
then doing max pooling over time which
is effectively sort of like choosing
which of these engrams best represents
the meaning of a word then what they do
after that is so at that point they've
got an output representation for
character engrams and so then they feed
that into a highway network like we
talked about a bit last time and then
the output of that then the word level
goes into an LS TM network and this LS
TM network is now word level LS TM
network and you're trying to sort of max
minimize perplexity like for the neural
language models we saw earlier so what
could they show with this well the first
thing they could show with it is that it
actually again just works well as a
language model
despite that skepticism that I hadn't
told you of about the fact of the matter
is you can build these kind of character
level models and train them and they
work to a first approximation as well as
word level language models but one of
the observations that they make is that
you can be getting as good results but
with much smaller models so up the top
here are their character level LS tier
models and word ones but the models they
built and here are whole bunch of models
over this data set and so as time went
by perplexities have been going down
gone to seventy eight point four and
their point was well we can build pretty
much as good a character model with 78.9
perplexity but our model is actually
much smaller this model here has 52
million parameters whereas our model at
works on a character level has only 19
million parameters so it's about 40% of
the size and that seems kind of
interesting but perhaps what's more
interesting as the sort of peek inside
it and see what happened
with the representation of words when
built out of characters and this part is
sort of actually a bit cool so what this
is showing is four words that are up the
top while here's you richard trading
it's asking what other words are most
similar to it according to the word
representations that's computed and the
top part is the output of a word level
STM model and that's sort of okay
Richard comes out of similar to Jonathan
Robert Neil and Nancy etc while although
letting though my nude mainly okay
but the patter it's sort of interesting
what happens with their character level
models and so in particular what's kind
of interesting is like first of all you
remember they sort of had the character
embeddings that went through the
convolutional layer and the max pool
wing and if at that point you ask what
things are most similar that basically
it's still remembering things about
characters so the most similar words to
while chilly whole meanwhile and white
so at least for the sort of first ones
they all end in le and you see that
pattern elsewhere right close to richard
hard rich richer richter that hardens an
ard rich that you're sort of just
getting this character sequence
similarity it's not really doing meaning
at all
but interestingly when they then putting
it through the highway layers that the
highway layers is successfully learning
how to transform most character sequence
representations into something that does
capture meaning so if you then say at
the output of the highway layers what
words are most similar then it seems to
be working pretty well while I was
similar to meanwhile Richard is similar
to Edward Gerard would Carl that is sort
of now working much more like a word
level model in capturing semantic
similarity so that seems kind of cool so
then they say well what about if we ask
about words that aren't in the
vocabulary
the model well if they're not in the
vocabulary of the model the word level
model can't do anything them so that's
why you get those dashes there and what
they're wanting the show is that the
character level model still works pretty
well so if you give it look with seven
O's in the middle of it that it's
correctly deciding that look looks look
looking are actually the most similar
words to that which is actually working
very nicely and some of the other
examples are sim what a computer-aided
is seen as most similar to computer
guided computer driven computerized
computer you're getting pretty similar
sensible results and then the little
picture on the right is sort of showing
one of these 2d visualizations of the
units that have been learnt and so the
red the red things are word character
prefixes the blue things are character
suffixes the orange things are
hyphenated things like in the middle of
computer-guided
and gray is everything else and so
there's some sort of sense since we're
just picking out different important
parts of words okay and that's I also I
guess just another good example of how
you can sort of compose together
different kinds of building blocks to
make more powerful models that you might
also want to think about for your final
projects
okay so here's back to one other example
from a neural machine translation system
of doing this hybrid architecture that
has word level and character level I
showed you earlier a purely character
level model I mean we'd built that out
of interest to see how well it did but
we were sort of really wanting to build
a hybrid model because that seemed like
it'd be much more practical to build
something that translated relatively
quickly and well so the idea was we
mainly build a word level neural machine
translation
system but would be able to work with
character level stuff when we had rare
or unseen words and that turned out to
work pretty successfully at improving
performance so the idea of that model is
this that we were going to run a pretty
standard sequence to sequence with
attention lsdm neural machine
translation system in my picked I mean
it's actually a four level deep system
but in my picture I showed lesson four
levels stack to make it easier to see
things and we're going to run this with
a reasonable vocabulary of sixteen
thousand words so for common words we
just have word representations that
we're feeding into our neural machine
translation model but for words that
aren't in the vocabulary we're going to
work out a word representation for them
by using a character level LS TM and
conversely when we start to generate
words on the other side we have a soft
max with a vocabulary of sixteen
thousand it could just generate words
like earth char but one of those words
is the UNK symbol and if it generates
the UNK symbol we then run a carrot Li
take this him representation and feed it
in as the initial input into a character
level lsdm and then we have the
character with level lsdm generate a
character sequence until it generates a
stop symbol and we use that to generate
words okay so we end up sort of with
this sort of hybrid composed stack of
eight lsdm layers yeah and you always
get something for your accent also if
you wanted to get the proper gradient
you you would always have to run
but what what do you cut it off and say
you only run like doing training you
only run the character level Alice TM
when the accent woman sees the highest
so at training a training time there's a
determinate piece of text right you know
the source and you know the target and
so we're and at training time we've
already decided our vocabulary right so
we've just decided what are the 15999
most common words those an uncle our
vocabulary so for both the input and the
output side we know which words aren't
in our vocabulary and so if it's not in
our vocabulary we're running this one if
if what was the output is not in our
vocabulary running that one and
otherwise we're just not running it at
all yeah and so and and the big that I
didn't explain but is actually important
and perhaps related like when we're
calculating a loss that we can back
propagate that sort of up here there are
sort of two losses there's a loss at the
word level that you know you'd like to
in this position give probability one to
generating UNK but really this model
will softmax will say Uncas you know
probability point two or whatever so
there's a loss there and then
secondarily there's a particular
sequence of characters you want to
generate and you've also got a loss
because you've loved the probabilities
you put over the characters so then I
think we saw I think Abby saw briefly
mentioned this commonly the decoders do
some kind of beam search to consider
different possibilities before deciding
the highest probability one over
sequence of words and so this was doing
a slightly more complex version of that
so there's a word level beam search when
running it and then also doing a
character a whole beam search to
consider different possibilities and so
if you want to integrate the the two of
those together but essentially
this worked pretty well so this was the
winning system and WMT 2015 which used
30 times as much data and ensemble
together three other systems compared to
the data that was provided for the task
this was the system I showed before they
got eighteen point three and if you
remember our carrot purely character
level system got eighteen point five
then by building this hybrid system that
we were able to build a much better
system there's about two and a half blue
points better than our then either this
word level or the character level system
so that was kind of nice and in
particular that was the state-of-the-art
at the time now of course if you are
paying very close attention that's now
nowhere near the state-of-the-art
because when I showed you that slide way
earlier of the Google system you will
have noticed that they have much higher
numbers in the 20s but that's what
happens as the years go by
okay but here's an example that shows
these different systems working and some
of the mistakes they make here's a
cherry-picked example where our system
the hybrid system works perfectly
because what else would you expect to
see and so you know you can see some of
the defects of things that can go wrong
so in this case you know the character
level system didn't work here
because it just sort of starting with
the stiff it sort of seemed to
free-associate a completely made-up name
that doesn't really have anything to do
with the source so that one isn't very
good the word level system went bung
here so you remember when it generates
an UNK the word level system would have
when it generates is using attention so
when it wants to generate it has
attention back to words and the source
and when it generates aren't Godot
two strategies it can either do unigram
translation of the word that is
maximally putting attention on or it
could copy the word that is maximally
putting attention on so in this case it
chose to translate the word or maximally
putting attention on but the word owes
maximally putting attention on was after
rather than diagnosis and so you just
get this Popo coming out of after after
and we completely lost the word and in
this example in this example how hybrid
system just ends up working beautifully
and gives you exactly the right
translation yay
of course it's not always that good in
the real world so here's a different
example so this is the example I showed
before with the 11-year old daughter and
in this example the hybrid model has the
same strength of the character model it
correctly generates 11 years old at a
character level in its translation but
you know this time for whatever reason
it's the hybrid model that goes bung in
generating the names and it translates
shiny Bart as Graham Bart whereas the
character level model gets it right
actually I think this is one of the
weaknesses of this hybrid model compared
to the character level model that
because of the character level generator
is kind of this sort of second level so
the purely character level model it's
able to use the character sequence as
conditioning context very effectively
whereas our hybrid model although we
feed the hidden representation of the
word level model in as the starting
hidden representation of the character
level model it doesn't have any
representations further back than that
of what's in the word level model and so
it tends not always do as good a job at
representing of capturing the context
that allows it to do translation of
things like names okay
very almost finished but there's just
sort of one thing I wanted to mention
before the end which is almost a
practical thing so we started off with
word embeddings but now we've been
talking a lot of character level models
so surely just for word embeddings you
should be able to do useful things with
them with characters or pieces of words
and that's something that people start
to play with so in this cow and ray
paper they said well let's train a word
to Veck model using exactly the same
loss as word to Veck users but let's
rather than having word representations
let's start with character sequences and
run a bi-directional lsdm to work out
word representations and we'll then sort
of be effectively training this more
complex model where we're learning
character and beddings and lsdm
parameters and that will give us our
word representations and that's an idea
that people have continued to play with
and so in particular I just wanted to
mention these fast text embeddings so a
couple of years ago people now at
Facebook the same tomash Mikhailov who
did the original word to Veck brought
out a new set of embeddings the fast
text embeddings and their goal was to
sort of have a next-generation word to
Veck which is sort of an efficient fast
word vector learning library but was
better for rare words and languages with
lots of morphology and the way they did
it was that they sort of essentially
took the word to vex skip grande model
but they augment it to put in character
engrams so more precisely this is what
they did so when you had a word my
example word is where for some Engram
size you represent it as a set of in
gram so this is kind of just about like
those whiffle phones I mentioned right
at the beginning where you have a kind
of a boundary symbol so you know the
beginning of the words so if the length
is 3
have beginning of word wh-wh eh er er e
re end of word as pieces of
representation and then you have an
additional one for just the whole word
so you do still have whole word
representations in this model
so where is represented by six things
and so then you're going to use all six
of those things in your computation so
if you sort of remember the guts of word
to vac that what you're doing was you're
doing these vector dot products between
your context representation and your
Center word representation so they're
going to do exactly the same thing but
for the Center word they're going to use
all six of these vectors that well all
their vectors corresponding to all six
of these representations and they're
going to some month and so you're just
doing this simple summing operation and
that sort of then giving you your
representation of similarity very
precisely they don't quite do that
because there's a hashing trick but I'll
leave that out but what they're able to
show is that that model actually works
pretty successfully so these are words
similarity scores skip grab their old
SIBO and then this is the sort of new
model that uses these kind of engrams
and in this you know at least for one of
the English datasets it doesn't get any
better but what they especially noticed
is for languages that have more more
more morphology that you're sort of
getting some fairly clear gains 70 69 on
275 59 60 on 266 in the right column so
these word piece models do give them a
better model of words and and just
practically fast text library now has
sort of word embeddings for about 60 or
70 different languages sort of a good
source of word embeddings for
multilingual applications okay I think I
am done so it thanks a lot and see you
again next week